[Music]
I'm Jennifer shadi and I'm gonna be here
for two weeks in st. Louis I'm really a
frequent visitor to this town I come
pretty much every year for the US Chess
Championships to do commentary and
oftentimes one or two other times around
the year for any of your other wonderful
events at the Museum or here at the
Chess Club and today is my first day
here I actually just landed a few hours
ago well today I wanted to show you one
of the most beautiful games I've seen in
really many years probably over ten
years I can remember seeing such a great
game in a long time and this is from a
recent tournament in Holland the Tata
Steel tournament in vehicons II and that
also included one of the players that
many of you must know Hikaru Nakamura he
was playing in that tournament but the
game that I want to look at is won by
vision on the reigning world champion
and his victory over world number three
Levon Aronian so a very exciting game
but first let me get a sense from you
like people talk a lot about beautiful
games like wonderful games what do you
think really makes a great chess game
your favorite chess games anybody have
one is it your does anybody have a
favorite just came that somebody else
played or is your favorite game one that
you played how many people's favorite
game is one that they personally played
themselves okay that's good that's not
bad that's not bad
oh thank you thank you in my team my
that's pretty funny when you're playing
a game and it's like not that
interesting and then you're just looking
at looking across your shoulder and like
while bat games fun and how many people
have a game that somebody else play that
is their favorite yeah and what what's
that
or with the Danish so you think that
does that mean is that one of the big
things be about a beautiful game
sacrifices yeah usually a lot of a lot
of people like sacrifices and so many of
the most famous and beautiful games are
sacrificial in nature although you know
lots of fun games that don't involve any
sacrifices at all so let's take a look
at this position which kind of I brought
up because in the Anand Aronian game and
not later quoted this game as something
similar that he had studied he
remembered this game it's he called it a
classic game took place in 1907 so I
guess you could call that pretty classic
one of the reason that people like to
study classic game so much is because
people made more mistakes and a lot of
times it's more fun to look at games
where people are making errors at the
very highest level the players nowadays
have such a professional attitude
towards chess and sometimes there are
fewer mistakes so fewer mistakes you're
blunders a little bit less fun for
amateurs to gain enjoyment from it
anyway in this position it's a black to
move and black started a series of
beautiful sacrifices that ended in
victory so why don't you take a look at
this petition for a minute and try to
analyze as far as you can
work okay so somebody is suggesting to
move work to be three so your idea is
that I can't take with the bishop and if
I take with the Queen you do what okay
and what about if I play so if you play
what if I play the other obvious move
taking the Queen what do you want to do
now what that so you just want to go
work to e3 all right I mean so your idea
is basically if I take one of you three
I play quick I could take the knight
with a queen yes and I could probably
also take the rook and be up yeah I'm up
a lot of material there so that's what
that's one of the problems with
sacrificing too much that if you
sacrifice a lot of material and you win
a queen sometimes you're still down
material all right so you always need to
kind of keep a running account of what's
going on and anytime you're sacrificing
the stakes are higher so you have to be
even more aware of every possibility in
the position every capture every check
and I know that a Ronan was talking to
you guys about 40 moves and how
important forcing moves are can't really
stress that enough almost every game
that a amateur player has at some point
involves a force you move on wrong
either one that he missed or one that
his opponent could have played and would
have ended the game all right well let's
try worked 83 so this is another
sacrificial idea all right work takes c3
interesting and now what happens now if
the queen is captured I need to get rid
of these arrows I don't want the arrows
to be on the board let's see but oh how
do I can't
oh no it's all turned off the arrows you
know if you have chest bass make sure to
turn off create thread as arrow and
thread as arrow that's another little
tech thing I absolutely detest that it's
kind of like the MS word always telling
you when you miss power it's like I
misspelled that on purpose
same thing here I lift my queen and take
on purpose don't keep telling me that
okay worth d2 so now what happens if I
play queen takes D - well what do you
what happens after Queen takes to do
well there is no Queen
so we're if we're T - Queen tasty - oh
yeah Bishop takes e4 and then is that
checkmate
well okay let's hold on hold on everyone
let's just maybe let's raise our hand so
we're not all talking at once I'm so
work D - Queen takes you to Bishop takes
e4 check now remember this is the stage
where you sacrifice a lot of a material
so you want to be accurate like work f3
sure then Bishop takes f3 and you're at
the same place but you just gave up a
rock
so if wait was trying to wiggle out of
this well what would they play instead
of worked after a yes they would play
Queen G - right because it's the same
thing after work at three you would be
forced to play Queen G - except now you
still have that work on a flan right so
Rick D - Queen D - Bishop takes e4 Queen
G - now try to visualize that position
visualizing is so important to becoming
a better player and find the very best
move for black in that position to find
the very best move there exactly
that is the best movement for in for the
future let's raise our hands so that
more people can find it that way you can
get give more people the pleasure of
finding the end of the move so everybody
see that now I'm going to play it over
the board as well but just one more time
let's do it on our heads because again
that's very important work do - Queen d2
Bishop takes e4 check Queen force to
interpose - G - and then Rick comes to
h3 now that's a very good move because
it what is a threat
what's an immediate threat you see the
threat there anyone in the front yeah
very good and why is rook takes H -
checkmate
like what tactic is that utilizing right
okay and it's more important that you
found it very quickly and then you know
the name for it but somebody else know
the name yes pin exactly so we're taking
advantage of a pins so this reminded
Anand of his game which is guess just a
bit of foreshadowing but I think it's a
very pleasing finish let's just put it
on the board now that we've done the
work of looking at it in our head you
know it's very it's very important to
visualize but then you know you can give
yourself the pleasure of actually seeing
it play out so a really cool finish and
it's fortunate that white didn't have
any any Brooks developed otherwise there
would be a little checkmate over there
that would ruin the fun and here it's a
very pleasing position because the the
Queen is pinned and if you take the
bishop off it's checkmate
and this checkmate on h2 is just
unstoppable so what is this somebody at
you it's stoppable for one movers oh is
that what somebody's about to say maybe
you could play that work f2 or something
yeah all right so let's see now I'm
going to actually show you the game that
I was talking about earlier as soon as I
get back so how do people do study
classic games anybody again you have
been buying odd teas you do as well what
what what book do you usually used to
study in classic games
Oh door opening books like the ideas
behind the chest move something like
that I guess it's not even full games a
lot of times sometimes it is that's okay
nowadays usually when you search there's
so many more games catalog from recent
years that you'll just find in so many
more because games by amateur players
are now catalog and junior championships
which is like thousands and thousands of
games so generally when you look up an
opening you kind of have to like really
go out of your way to find the classic
games alright so let's take a look at
this game um Aaron Yan played a d4 how
many people here play d4 just out of
curiosity
wow that's about half is that right how
many people play you for Oh people play
both that's really serious and then some
people didn't raise their hands so I'm
assuming that you all play g4 in the
first move they play g4 or f4 no no a
non played d5 so you know a nod doesn't
necessarily have the most reputation for
having the most wild game so if you
start stop see the game start like this
you might think it's going to end up
being a pretty solid game but we
actually were in for a big treat so how
many people were paying attention to the
last world championship match yeah what
did you think of it yeah the last world
championship match actually was
interesting it coincided with the US
Chess Championship held here at the
Chess Club and people were constantly
remark that you know another draw in the
world championship in another day of
bloodshed in the US Chess Championship
and that is another reason why sometimes
the slightly lower level games can
actually be more exciting but not in
this case so this is the starting
position of the Slav and there's a few
different moves at black and pie hair I
don't I'm not a g4 player so and I've
never played this line it's well
actually I played this the slob is black
very briefly but I always find it
interesting to like look at openings
that I don't play and kind of understand
the basic logic behind the
so what are the top moves in this
position you somebody try to give me
like the the most the two of the three
most popular moves here see if you can
get two out of three what's that uh you
six is one nice em two out of three try
to get two out of three that's not in
the top Bishop g4 I guess you're trying
to say but that's not in the top three
yeah no the top three are all pawn moves
because you know when you put when you
move your bishop out you got to worry
about like Queen b3 stuff hitting b7 and
hitting d5 so yeah pawn takes c4 is one
big move and then there's one other
which is very odd Oh somebody already
said to you six that's the most popular
move which was played in this game hold
on yeah a 686 looks like a weird move
but it's also it used to be really
popular and the idea behind that is that
the b7 pawn can sometimes move to b5 and
bizarrely enough that sometimes the rook
can come to a7 to protect b7 very
strange but such things happen when you
are playing more closed positions but
anyway e 6 was played in this game by an
odd and Aronian played quieter system
III now black took on c4 and how do you
think black intends to complete his
development here because this bishop is
obviously really terrible right that's
one of the reasons why a lot of players
when they're starting out would it make
moves like e6000 so what do you think of
somebody raise their hand and tell me
what you think the plan for action for
that Bishop 1c it is yeah and the back
and blue shirt b5 but then even after b5
right where you want to put on Bishop e7
and then what I mean you're right but
like isn't that still bad
so in addition to playing [ __ ] would be
seven what would you probably want to do
one day ah well bring you to a six
wouldn't be that great either because
then there would just be like a pawn in
front of it
and by the time you get all that in I
guess you maybe you could play before
and hope that you would score something
but probably it's too artificial it's
not really going to work out yeah
exactly so basically you want to try to
play for B 5 and C 5 which might be a
little bit hard to arrange because if
you try to play B 5 and see if I
immediately the BFI pawn would just be
hanging but you know there might be a
couple different ways to deal with it
and we'll see how I'm on did so and I'm
to play b5 immediately and then white
plays Bishop to d3 and now you can see
like again the special basics just
wouldn't work in fact it would create a
pin I could even maybe play a four and
the bishop would be very awkward so he
develops see some normal moves here
Queen c2 very typical move and now black
plays Bishop db7
and here there are a few different moves
well he starts with a three and now work
to c8 was played another way to play for
c5 besides playing work c8 is why your
work c8 puts the work on the same file
as the Queen which is always kind of a
nice thing it's just kind of barreling
down that Queen if things get traded the
Queen is going to look very awkward on
the same file as a rock right but
another way another like even more
direct way to prepare c5 would be to
just simply protect this pawn on d5 and
how would you do that a six right yeah
so that that's another possibility but a
non-planar works to c8 in this game and
this was also preparation for his match
against Gelfand so Gelfand also a d4
player
and that's an instructive I think true
because we saw that in the US Chess
Championship this year one of the very
best games of the tournament the best
game I think it was picked as the best
game right was actually preparation for
another candidates match not a World
Championship match but it was a
preparation for a candidates match
against Apollo anybody know which player
I'm talking about fine go to the back
knows I really like this game I would
show this game - except it involves a
very popular guy at the Chess Club so I
don't know so the answer is gata Kamsky
gotta Kamsky played this very beautiful
preparation against yasser sarah juan in
this year's US Championship in a won the
best game of the tournament
so the point of that is that sometimes
you can do work on chess and it might
not realize itself immediately you might
have a tournament where you know you
study the sicilian for weeks and you
don't even get a single sicilian but it
will always eventually come up so work
to c8 and now what do you think some
typical moves for white would be here
just come up because when you don't play
d4 sometimes you look at these positions
and you're like I don't know what I
would do so it's a good exercise because
you just never know what types of
positions you might find yourself in
just moves it seemed to improve your
position considering that most of your
development is completed what do you
think
Knight to g5 are you talking about white
or black it's White's move now because
the Beaufort reasonable idea is but
you're talking about Wyatt yeah okay
that that's definitely a good idea okay
ninety-five hitting h7 I mean normally
you don't do that but now you're you're
really pressuring this and you're also
controlling you four so definitely make
sense what else we're so just some other
ideas yeah Ricky or D yeah we're you're
d1 both seem to have some logic to them
I kind of I feel a little bit more
partial to do you want myself because I
feel like I might if I play e4 it's
gonna be more important to keep this one
protected but you know both make sense
what else
well b4 makes a lot of sense and I mean
that's a very carpeau vien move because
you know they like to talk about Karpov
as the king of prophylaxis and the idea
was that he was very good at defending
against their opponent his opponent
strats right and before you see that
black doesn't have a whole lot of ideas
in this position he probably wants to
play c5 maybe you know you want to play
e5 in some situations but after playing
Bishop e7 if I doesn't really fit the
position as well right if I would be a
move you want to play if you were trying
to get your Bishop out on this diagonal
so you want to play c5 so why not just
stop his only idea
well that move has been playing and
blacks found some tactical ways around
it by actually playing c5 anyway which
is not really the type of move that's
going to be easy to find over the board
but one of the big ideas here is that
this Bishop is attacking this knight on
f3 and white is going to be forced to
hurt his pawn structure by recapturing
so we didn't just go look at a sample
line here and now after Bishop f3 gf3
blacks just sacrificed a piece but he
has really a lot of threats partly based
on this King and equally as important
we've got this this Knight pinned and
were threatening to play things like 90
five in Queen to h4 and it's actually
very very dangerous for ye like if white
just plays I think I was looking like
what if white just plays like some
normal moves there already it is almost
a disaster look at black play here
Bishop e5 I think the problem with
Bishop e5 is maybe I can just go Queen
d2 yeah we want to be working now we've
got our pin and we want to work on the
other angle same thing I would probably
try it wide probably maybe I play I have
more choices than maybe I could play
Queen B 2 or Queen d2 maybe B 4 B 4 K
before it's a good idea and then if I
take on before you want to play Knight
before but I also have a bishop takes h7
check and then move my queen maybe Queen
G Phi check and then King H 1 Queen for
seems like a pretty good idea
Bishop H 2 also is an interesting idea
and then after Queen h4 check King G 1
what can white book and black do now
come back through yeah Oh Knight takes
III I thought you're going - yeah well
Knight well we're all suggesting he's
suggesting Knight e3 I was thinking
Knight c3 but Knight e3 should be good -
the only problem ie 3 though
well yeah I mean in this one in this one
that the problem is the Queen can
interpose and you get quite a lot of
material here you have actually three
pieces and a rope
yeah whereas in the other way in the
other way when you play Knight takes c3
now yes and the work is also the work is
also coming to h5 which you know if you
if you try to play like f4 or something
here so okay anyway just just give a bit
of an example of how blacks position
actually has some hidden power in it
based on some of these factors that we
mentioned earlier namely that the rook
and the Queen are in the same file and
that this bishop is potentially
dangerous if the diagonal opens up so b4
definitely a very interesting idea but
black had some tactical means to stop it
and that's just a good example in chess
where positionally b4 is just an
absolutely brilliant move but black has
some tactical resources that make it
less awesome now one thing I noticed
when we were going for some of the
tactical lines is again forcing moves
really important so instead just looking
at the first forcing move you see you
want to really kind of look at all the
possibilities and then go through them
one by one until you find the best one
on that generally is what good players
do so instead white could play Knight to
g5 here which was suggested by you as
your first suggestion so Aronian played
this move and now here's where black
played the move that he had been
preparing for
Gelfand you played a c5 immediately in
this position another pasta another
tactical possibility here for black is
what
so [ __ ] aah - this is a very typical
sacrifice and what's the idea
and then after Knight g4 you can take
this right but this didn't end up being
that amazing for for black because you
know he's starting to get pushed back
Bishop is still bad on b7 so a nun
decided to do something she thought was
better played Knight g5 c5 and now white
took on h7 athonite
and black played Knight g4 and now
sometimes our ideas of playing g6 right
and you know and uh entrapping but I'm
but in this situation that's just plate
I'm saying like instead you could have
considered something like Knight takes
h7 Bishop h7 King h8 sometimes there are
moves like g6 in these positions but a
lot of times y can play Bishop takes g6
and that would have definitely pertained
if white head instead of taking with a
knight taken with a bishop now after
King h8 it's always kind of interesting
can black play g6 or will Bishop takes
g6 and response be too strong that's
kind of a whole nother world of
variations and stick to the stuff now
there's a lot happening here on h2 what
happens if white were to play something
like Knight takes f8 raise your hand
guys but somebody tried to checkmate me
here try to get it
yeah okay so you wanna start with Bishop
takes h2 okay that leaves me with one
move and then Queen h4 and then I'm
already basically out of options right
so that's not too hard
so I even really think too much about
Knight take safe at f8 immediately but
still these are all things that have to
be won over when you're sacrificing
whenever you sacrifice you really need
to look at all the possibilities so
instead white played four in this
position to block this attack and now
black took on d4 opening up the rock and
then white recaptured and now what do
you think black play and take your time
on this and the somebody's already
somebody might have already seen the
game
I'm just going to I'm just going to hang
out here until you get the move
this is actually like a really weird
move it's very very odd so I don't it's
not something that's really easy to find
in like 30 seconds or something like
that but it just keep looking for
creative ideas can't hurt and also think
about whatever idea you have think about
maybe how white could defend against it
just one second
so by the way I had asked a question is
anybody seen this game before well how
is it that a person in the room who
knows the most about chess it's just so
strange hard work pays off guys um yeah
what was your idea well what's the
problem with 93 yeah see that's funny
how as soon as you as soon as I point to
that square you see it you know that's a
funny thing about chess a lot of times
people don't realize they blender until
they make the move it's almost like when
you're thinking your brains in a
different space then after you've made
your decision
it's very weird what's normal is what is
a normal move right okay okay so you're
looking at Queen h4 because that would
seem to be like number one in the
candidate moves last but then you know
maybe after Queen h4 what do you think
white might do well h3 probably yeah I
would probably I would probably play h3
before g3 because this bishop but yeah
it doesn't seem like there was an
immediate follow up there so you're
looking at things like night just but
Knight to c5 with the idea that if one
c5 Bishop c5 King h1 maybe there's
something going on in the square okay
but that is but that is basically very
similar to what an on came up with
actually but the move he came up with
here is just very weird it's not really
like anything I've seen before exactly
very I have you seen
quite like this before then I feel like
this very unusual attack bag it's a bit
strange you worked you worked on
something with words or something
similar
oh Emily line yeah it's very strict it's
creative because it's like if there's
certain tactics that even though they
might they might seem really weird
they've been played so many times in
other situations that it's it's a bit
more routine whereas this one is very
strange and somebody just mentioned a
move did somebody mention a move
no not f5 well one of the things that
one thing that might help you is that in
chess when you're attacking the most
important thing is usually to try to get
your Queen into the pie effectively
because without a queen a text usually
do not work and that's why players are
usually desperate to trade Queens if
they feel like they're getting attacked
we'll actually see that later in this
game as well so we tried Queen Age
foreign somehow even though that seems
like a great way to get the Queen in
doesn't lead to anything immediate so a
non found a very creative way to get his
queen in in another way yeah well you
mean Bishop to c5 yeah there is nothing
on c5 right now
yeah Bishop to Bishop to c5 is just
absolutely very astonishing your move
it's almost hard to believe that it's
real right this trips just sitting there
right but the idea is that if pawn takes
e5 Knight a c5 now the big thing here is
really that the Queen coming to d4 is
like a serious issue like what if white
were to play let's say white we're to
play Bishop e2 here or something now
what
just just to remove the bishop from
attack because the knight and the queen
we're both attacking it right now what
can black do kind idea okay so we're at
Queen where okay Queen d4 check alright
and now can you h1 okay so Knight up two
and now if I play King g1 what happens I
know you guys all know this you all know
this you all know this yeah huh
okay Knight h3 check King h1 yes Queen
g1 so that's a that's the classic
smothered mate that we all love to play
beautiful even though it's extremely
beautiful it's actually more common than
many other types of check mates and
whatnot I always usually the first like
really really beautiful the thing that
an amateur player gets to do that's a
nice thing about this mother and me but
eventually you get to play it and it
just feels so good and so if you're on
the other side of it and your opponent
does get that smother made in you should
you should let them play this mother may
come on let them play Knight absolutely
chess is so hard you suffer so much to
get good at this game you know you
deserve it so of course after Knight F
to the big the big question would be
what if he just takes an eye in and
after queen up - this is a bit unusual
situation because it's actually just
impossible for white to defend right I
mean what is it what are the two threats
yet Queen G - made and and you know you
can stop that maybe but then you can't
stop the other threat of Queen e1 I
ain't so if you play something like
Bishop d1 or you know to stop this you
know will person there's also Bishop key
to mate so it's just like they're just
way too much going on here
so that's really the idea I mean that's
really the crux is the idea that by
playing Bishop c5 DC 595 Queen d4 is in
the position so it's very strange of
course there's a little bit better
resistance here than playing Bishop to
e2 there's also Queen e2 so that after
Queen d4 check King h1 there's a little
bit more coverage but now of course you
lose the bishop so that doesn't turn out
so great for white either so let's go
back and see what actually happened in
the game so instead of playing pawn
takes Bishop in this position Aronian
played Bishop to e2 immediately hitting
this Knight oh I don't want to show you
that right away but sorry haha but yeah
this is where the position starts to get
really interesting and then on just like
uncorks number of sacrifices so he's
really determined as you can see to make
this threat occur Queen d4 and so he
plays knight on d5 in this position
which really fits with the what we just
looked at I mean he could play Bishop
takes d4 check and get his Bishop to g4
but obviously that's not as good as
getting the Queen there right like I
mean you can compare you've won the
exchange but you don't have your queen
infiltrated and so of course this is all
very concrete at this level tactics tend
to be very concrete you can't make that
many generalizations but one of the main
general principles that I glean from
this game is the Queen in the attack
you've got to get the Queen in the
attack because that's really how you win
when you're attacking so night on duty
e5 absolutely astonishing move again and
now of course this pawn can't take
because it's a pin right
if this pawn takes we have some some
really similar stuff to what we just saw
all right Queen d4 check King H one
night f2 is still really bad right
same smother mate so you can't take that
can't take that so what else is there
take here again now you have an even
faster mate right just a kind of
accelerated version of the same thing
so instead our own yawn in this position
remove the bishop I mean so I remove the
knight on g4 and now black played Bishop
takes d4 check King h1
they take g4 so it's always good to take
a little step back and count the
material in a position so what's the
situation now
yeah shockingly after all the stuff it
is even for the moment now what do you
think white will do here okay finally
why don't were even so why don't we just
take some ticks of material and this is
actually exactly what happened they
takes a faint now what do you think
about some moves here for black what are
your candidate moves trying to come up
with some candidate moves here for black
so you finally acquiesced to taking with
the pot the bishop on d4 and so again it
becomes a question of how you're going
to get your Queen into the am Queen b6
the problem is you really in order
attack with your queen you really kind
of need your queen to be on front that's
why I think a non made such pains to try
to play Queen to d4 check cuz then he
was able to get the smothered mate
right like if we can put our queen here
well now not anymore because the queen
is blocking but when the bishop wants on
you to like we can put our queen here
always like a forest mate right if we
can put our queen somewhere where we're
attacking h2 or g2 we're going to be
checkmating but when we put on Queen b6
it's kind of like the battery is in the
wrong direction right you don't even
well yeah that would be what we would
normally look at Queen to h4 right Queen
to h4 would seem to be a good idea in
this position because we're threatening
checkmate and if they play h3 what
happens go go yeah Queen just Queen
takes h3 because upon is pin so pins are
coming up in this position in this game
a lot actually so they can't play h3
they can't play g3 because its pin by
this Bishop so it looks like a really
good move except what can white do and
this also relates that theme that I'm
talking about about how important the
Queen is when you're attacking okay yes
exactly Queen to h7 check this is a very
typical tactic that occurs when one side
is trying to attack the other side will
go to pains to try to find
weird and creative ways to trade Queens
because once you're getting attacked in
your trade Queens you can really relax
breathe a sigh of relief
sometimes you're losing anyway but at
least you won't get checkmate in
obviously that's not that's not really
totally serious
but after Queen takes h7 Knight takes h7
king cakes h7 now materialize for the
very moment white is up
but the problem is are some threats here
right there's a lot there's a there's a
pretty nasty threat of night to f2 Jack
I mean yeah you can't really you can't
really put another another piece to
guard that very easily
I guess your only way to try to just
hang on and guard and just be like
really what's the word passive would be
to play 91 but that would fail to Wyatt
so this would this would this would stop
Knight up to and for the moment it looks
like everything's protected but the
problem would be the black would play
yes work c2 here is a very good move and
now we also see the power of the two
bishops in this game so even though
black is technically down in material
this position is just totally crushing
here it's actually impossible to defend
this and of course these sleeping pieces
do not help very well I wish I could
make them another color just like green
is good this should be like some bad
color uh yeah
usually I think a lot of times we use
red for for bad in chess right so
instead why it would have to play
something you know would have to just
you know defend in the night act to
check and Knight d3 yeah so that's why
Queen h4 is not the best so any other
thoughts here for back by the Queen
assures not like losing for black or
anything as we were showing like you
know black actually has a pretty decent
position there but I just can't I can't
get away from the fact that we none
really wanted more from this position he
didn't want to just get like a good end
game or liquidate in any way he wanted
to try to win in the middle game and the
only way to do that is to completely
avoid queen drains right so even after
Queen h4 queen h7 check I was showing
lines where black was doing pretty well
it was pretty well not totally winning
so a non leader said that this was his
best move of the game yeah okay
three moves sequence okay we should take
night yeah wait wait wait Bishop takes
Knight in your st. whatever where it
goes you're saying if I take back with a
pawn or something what but how does the
Queen take the Queen what do you mean
what are you saying
are you or were you trying to play like
okay um well it's always good to look at
it's always good to look at attacking
move so there's nothing wrong with
looking at that like you could look at
Bishop c3 pawn c3 and Herald I would I
would I would probably look at this move
but then I would probably stop because I
would just look at like Queen h4 and say
well Queen 87 seems reasonable there -
even more reasonable because we trade
off one of our bishops so yeah I would
probably stopped at that point oh I see
okay close well the problem what's the
problem of g6 in this position well
what's the first thing you would look at
if your opponent plays g6 yeah I mean
Knight takes and besides this Knight was
kind of doomed anyway except now they
play Knight takes g6 and that actually
looks really good so all of a sudden
white actually seems to be the attacker
which is pretty shocking considering the
circumstances right so but close it was
very close yeah f5 was played f5 really
a brilliant move because and this is the
kind of move that people tend to like
because it's what we call in chess a
quiet move right like moves like Bishop
c5 very flashy Knight to e5 like all
these different pieces are the smothered
mate that several of you found with you
know Queens you want these are really
nice moves but it's a move like FY which
is actually extremely difficult to find
I mean it's
just it seems that there's so many
pieces in an attack and you're just
making this move to stop Queen to h7
check it's pretty cool and you're
allowing white to move his Knight to g6
right which is what happened and now
what do you think black played well the
Queen can't go to h4 now right because
the knight stopping it and I somebody
said Queen something seven oh you said
King Day hmm okay so your ideas you want
the night to move away um yeah that
makes some sense but an unfounded
different way to go about that well the
English King
the thing with King f7 is that allows
Knight e5 stuff to come with check which
I'm not sure you want no black Lee Queen
to f6 enter Queen to f6 attacking the
knight on g6 and now it's in the heart
of the position but unfortunately it's
stranded right so it's kind of the
opposite of an outpost Knight a dead
post yeah an outpost Knight is when a
knight isn't a really NS square in the
heart of the position and it's protected
by a pond right now this this this
Knight can't be at attacked by pawns but
it's also not protected by a bond so
it's not good so wait played h3 here and
now how do you think this game finished
off there's still a few more moves left
yeah that Queen takes do sex occurred
yeah
and now if Quan takes G for what happens
now create six checks really bad
actually that's a really bad movie you
have to tie this one come on
no they're the same move sorry it's just
a matter of style really the more
aggressive player will play queen 8x the
more positional player plays eight seven
so instead of f one takes you for white
played Queen d2 now what do you think
black did
Queen age 5 was playing yet okay so now
what's somebody somebody was paying
attention earlier what is blacks threat
now let's raise our hands
everybody's it's slightly different
levels in this class um
yes again Queen Tate's h3 taking
advantage of this pin it's so easy to
see it it's so easy to see it kind of
over the board I mean when you're in a
lesson but sometimes it's really hard to
see that over the board and in fact I
think there was a game in the US Women's
Championship last year where in the heat
of the battle and a time pressure
scramble somebody missed something like
that so that's why you have to really
get these tactics down like cold and do
your tactic training online or with
books how many people use books to study
tactics how many people use a tactic
strain are like an online program how
many people don't really study tactics
oh no
tactics are easier than ever to study
because there's a bunch of online
programs that just spit at you problems
from chest tempo to chest calm the ICC
they're really even to game not I mean
there's so many programs well the Texas
might different quality like some of a
couple of them might have cooks but
doesn't really matter the main purpose
is to just keep doing them over and over
and drilling yourself just like you
drilled multiplication tables when you
were seven right
I don't know when do you do
multiplication tables I'm also concept
of had eight nine okay so you're way
past that right your bad side so a queen
takes h3 here is the red so white
stopped it with Queen d3 and now what
now what can blank do
then nobody called this one out because
it's really basically the last move of
the game so we want to see this okay so
if somebody's got it let's see if a
couple other people can get it before we
give the answer I
okay we got a couple people who seem to
have answers here
I was actually having a debate with Alex
Marlar here at the club earlier about
whether it's useful to know names for
tactics or whether you should just like
think about chess whether that actually
defeats the purpose like having a name
for something kind of like just confuses
you and make things harder I'm of the
opinion that have any names for tactics
is really great because if you know for
instance about an in-between move or a
score you when you see it on the board
the fact that you have a name for it
makes it pop out a little bit more and
in this case I guess we could call this
a combination of pin because we've seen
Queens a ch3 bunch but there's also
another tactic at work here somebody who
has the answer don't tell me what the
answer is yet but give me the name of
the other tactic that's at work air
interference very good okay so
interference is when you block block or
interference basically synonyms so you
have the answer to you do okay anyone
else okay that was a big hint so it's a
combination of pin and the blocking
more hands you got it you got an idea -
okay oh you got you already got it got
it
you got you you got it in the back
you've got it also very good all right
you want to take a shot no it's not
night f29 of - doesn't I mean the thing
about night if - is it's a good idea
because it attacks the king in the Queen
at the same time but here you know you
really wanted to go for the final blow
and the problem here is that you know
we'll just take on f2 and that doesn't
lead to anything immediate after
beachwood days f2 but definitely
something that I would look at
um yeah I'm back I'm working three Oh
what's your idea after after pawn c3
might also anyone else I'm some you want
it what do you think okay very good is
it was that what you guys are thinking -
yeah and in 93 93 should be good - it's
Bishop III I think must be slightly
better that's when a non played because
if Knight e3 maybe they oh well maybe
you could play that keep something crazy
they can do on here I mean it looks
horrible it's I'm sure it's losing but
that's not even possible if you play
vish a b3 right and that is what what
was played and now after Bishop takes Oh
now after Bishop takes c3 we see the
beautiful point which we've mentioned
many time in analysis which is why now
what can black play no we don't wanna
play Knight F - you keep wanting to win
that Queen but we you know we don't need
to win the Queen if we have checkmate
right
it's a nice one right what's up yeah
it's very good Queen tastes h3 and again
we're taking advantage of this pin and
it's it's meet next move so a very
beautiful game by and on in a very
classical style not that type of game
you normally see at that nosebleed 2700
plus level alright a lot of times these
guys are just making more intricate
moves that you can't even understand
whereas here we have this beautiful
sacrifices that we can actually digest
which is great um is a refutation of the
move it's probably that might be a
strong word but Anand did say that it
was a novelty and obviously it turned
out very well so no I don't think
erroneous mistake actually a nun was a
said in the press conference and he I
want I think he wasn't so sure about the
move f4 for one thing when he when he
guarded against h2 with f4 and then
probably the big mistake hmm he also
Bishop e2 when instead of taking on c5
and allowing Knight takes e5 he thought
maybe he should try that and you know
just stop Queen d4 well it definitely is
definitely dangerous to capture um you
know to capture but I guess you see I'm
sure he had analyzed it as well and
probably just didn't see the Bishop c5
idea
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]